Okay. Let's look at the solution for our
computer architecture quiz. The question was, what computer
architecture is about. Is it about building faster
transistors? It is not. Computer architecture is about, maybe
finding how to use these faster transistors to
build better computers in some way. Is it about
how to build faster computers? It is. One
of the possibilities for how computers can be better
if they're faster, so if we need a
faster computer, computer architecture is definitely about how to
do that. How to build larger larger buildings. This
is not correct. How to design energy efficient computers,
again energy-efficiency, that is what we're after is
a way of improving computers, so we definitely are
interested in that in computer architecture. How to build
buildings that fit more computers. This again is about
buildings, not about building computers, so this is not true. And how
to build computers that fit better into buildings, is about building computers
that are more suited for some purpose, in this case, fitting more
of them into buildings, so computer architects might be worried about this.